okay
welcome everybody to another live stream
um this is reviewing geometry and
graphics functionality
for upcoming version 12.2 and
um right because i just happen to notice
this immediately collinear see what on
earth is the relationship of that
to the synthetic geometry collinearity
tester
uh
well this is a fast primitive this is
okay so as a precursor to this
one part here is to make the whole
geometry
subsystem uh more robust and higher
performing
yeah that's not going to yeah go ahead
go ahead
no we can we can we can avoid providing
it to our users it just means that they
won't have a way to write it
faster no i'm not talking about that i'm
talking about the fact that
in synthetic geometry there is a
collinearity testing
mechanism right what is a geometric
assertion or what
is it i think it's a geometric assertion
yes okay
so you're saying which is okay i'm just
trying to understand the relationship of
the collinearity test
to geometric assertions i mean
i understand it's much more efficient
it's much you know it works in a
nanosecond or something but it is the
same functionality as geometric
assertion true or not true
i don't know we have to check okay which
it has to be the same
it has to be cholera but it doesn't
exactly do the same but in the cases
where they overlap it has to be the same
there's no other choice
okay well the difference is n dimension
it's work on symbolics
i don't care geometric assertion just
happens to only work in two dimensions
right now
no that we're not going to have a second
function anyway but
we'll talk about this i mean this thing
would have to be supported in
the symbolic synthetic geometry world
but that doesn't seem too difficult okay
let's start at the beginning here
um boy i've only i've only reported 63
bugs
no how many of these are mine from
graphs and networks
i mean everything you reported were
shakes i mean there is
spacing none of the bugs you reported
which are not fixed
that's excellent when do we get to have
um one thing i've really wanted
you know you know i've been using the
scraps and networks functionality
extensively and it's been working great
i mean given that the whole universe
happens to be one of these it's kind of
useful to have this functionality
um um
there are two things that i'm would be
very interested in one is
um ordered edges coming out of a node
that is essentially port numbers okay
and that's going to come up that's come
up already in the neural net framework
and the second thing is uh
a graph plot that is a down sampling
graph plot
i'm making sense yeah we're aware of
both of those
and we've spent some time on them so
question is when and what we prioritize
that over
yeah well i think the first question is
do we have plausible designs for them
uh no okay i think that sort of for the
down
sampling i think charles is now doing
actually a very good survey which will
tell us what
what's what's reasonable there that's
something we wanted to
have for a long time and it will affect
a lot of users
not so much ports will come in when we
try to do hierarchical graphs
look ports are coming in right now
because of the representation of neural
nets
and several other kinds of things where
there's a graphical notation
okay yeah but they're not coming in for
graphs no they're not okay
um oh they're not i agree so so
okay um but in terms of down sampling
i mean if you know things charles we
should put them in the function
repository for now
just particular algorithms for graph
down sampling
it's a practical matter today i have to
down sample some graphs do you have any
suggestions for how to do it
um yes i mean it depends on what
property or what
you know you wish your end goal from the
down sampling you want
but there is a you know i have like a
body dozen of those uh
alcohol prototype so
where can i can i play with one i mean
look
what i would like is just something that
has you know
the overall look of the graph you know
the placement of points is right but i'm
not
drawing all the points for instance that
would be a reasonable
criterion
oh okay well that one it's it's far much
easier yeah
i mean i can send you the gold later on
on that oh that'd be wonderful
really wonderful okay sandra on the
livestream is asking about voronoi in 3d
what's the story of voronoi in 3d what's
the what does the s mean
it's there i mean we have we've found
well it's planned for 12.2
yes yeehaw
that has been a long road roger 15 years
no no um
you know we we haven't had geometry
i know that but i mean i know well
anyway
okay okay but this i mean one of the
things that needed i mean there's still
one thing that's not done here okay so
one of the things it needed was
a general polyhedral cell
and we have now general polyhedra but
the other thing it needed now here is
the
because we we can only uh have bounded
um these cell complexes we need to clip
them against the bounding
box okay all right so
so are you saying that polyhedron now
has a different form
no no polyhedron is polyhedron but we
didn't have anything called polyhedron
before
but we had that only one right yes yes
yes
yes okay but when we launched geometry a
couple of years ago
okay convex region q
cool complex polygon convex polyhedron q
all seems sensible
convex hull okay
so most people are are mostly familiar
with the point case
in which case a convex hull of that is
going to be a polyhedra
in general right now you could have a
curved surface and you could ask for the
convex hollow curved surface and
principle
yes which is the smallest convex region
that includes that
and then it's going to have curved
pieces on it
it's not going to be a pointy thing
let's talk for a second about
the kind of calculus of what you can
apply these things to
right so i mean if i say convex region q
and then i just have a list of points
is it going to work it's going to be
false yeah i mean it's going to be false
obviously a list of points is not convex
well because you're insisting that they
put them inside a polygon
well a list of points is not convex it
has to include all the possible line
segments and that list of points
obviously doesn't include all the line
segments
okay so you're saying let's say i say
can i say i can't say square here but
can i say um regular polygon
true okay nice
okay so if i say in here if i say
region intersection a region union
of regular polygon with regular polygon
eight comma oh god the selection bug
drives me crazy
what's where's the argument for oh my
god and the raft is disappearing uh do
we have somebody from project management
here
again i need to report this this the
raft disappearing
and the selection bug so devendra
reported that got a response it's
apparently fixed
in a pr but it's not there yet
okay well can somebody tell me which
argument of regular of regular polygon
is the position um
the first argument is the position
okay
what does that mean how could that be
right or do i need to put this on a list
what's going on here yeah
i don't understand what's happening here
it doesn't look right
so um
oh you've got a radius and an angle
yeah this i see so this has got to be
like this
okay much better so now if i say
graphics of that dandy
and now this graphics object is not
going to be good enough but that region
object
actually did region instead of graphics
you could just work with it
what i'm saying yeah
okay
an unexpected unexpected bug or an
unexpected bug
have we seen non-expected
okay
you know my ability to find bugs is
really ridiculous
the thing that comes out is a polygon
how could that possibly
well i don't know maybe something
unstable on the system something
i mean we tested this so yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's got to be i mean
that just this is this is the this is d
base case
polygon and a base polyhedra based
polygon this is like the base case for
it
well assuming that that thing there
actually is
how would i get out the points in that
polygon
um put it on coordinate
and that was a fail um
yeah it should work can you make a note
of this
okay and now if i say convex region of
that
polygon of that then it will
okay okay what's center points as
annotations here
so when you do voronoi is
because what it gives you is basically a
minimum distance regions
so within this cell the minimum distance
is the point
that was the input point
okay and and for many applications you
want to know
what point is associated with what cell
and so people have asked for this and
it's completely reasonable
and we have annotations so we will use
annotations
to provide that you can extract the
center point okay for each cell
bounding region so that's an existing
function that's been extended
to to do ellipsoidal regions
yeah so that's one case that that's that
that's one more
type of bounding region which is the
minimum
volume oriented ellipsoid which is
you know very efficient very good to
have
which is you know it's very small volume
so it's
and it's it's using our optimize convex
optimization to compute
but the other thing you know go ahead
the other thing is actually works on
general regions that's a much bigger
extension in a way
so you can get the bounding region not
just for points
but for for any region so women so so
what we've got here
so if you look at the source you'll see
this this this new thing
okay well hold on let's um if i say
what you're saying fast ellipse here
yeah
the hell why didn't that work
uh
i'll stay
what's 10 oh that was okay oh no that's
just the coordinates it wasn't the
polygon
no but that should work with the points
in this case some something is really
high in this building something is
really you just work okay so fine
seriously busted in this build okay
find out what build it is
yesterday okay
all right but if you look at that source
you can see
the the documentation source for
bounding region
running region new okay
and so this thing of applying to any
region
that's substantial i like it i like it i
like it i like it it's basically fitting
a um whatever around the region
yes and see these bounding regions are
all convex
so they're simple in that way so for
instance
right you often we use them a lot
internally
to get faster code fast negative
criteria
but you can it's not hard to imagine why
you want it
let's say you have a robot arm that's
going to collide with its environment
sure sure
but the one argument form of bounding
region should also work for a region
right not just the one with the form so
you should document that
make sense right right i see what you're
saying
but this sounds like a very useful
function it is
it's just been made even better
good okay sound on the livestream is
asking for can the voronoi
can the polygons return in the original
order
what's the original what's a region so
so in other words
what that means is presumably if the
voronoi
region so so right now if i say voronoi
mesh
of let's say percent 10
why didn't that work well i don't know
what about this
just i don't think no lost hope in this
build now
okay fine let's just start up a regular
12-1
or should i start a regular 12-2 head
branch let's do it 12. no
there's nothing head branch oh no there
should be
what's in 121 yeah the 2d should work
okay let's get this and i'll just look
at this for a second
god this startup is so freaking slow for
these things
oh it's because we were starting the
docky tools stack
okay so what we're talking about here
let's say we say voronoi
mesh of this
okay now those cells presumably if i how
can i get those cells out
it's like how you get the cells from a
mesh so mesh cells
it's a mesh that you get there's a mesh
region
and there's no way that they are related
to that original
so no you can't well the list of
polygons here
why can't list of polygons be in the
order of those initial points
no um why not there's no way why
why do a list of polygons
list the polygons here right doesn't it
you're asking for a special
canonicalization and it makes no sense
there on the other hand we can get the
points out
that are the center points they can be
annotations and that's what i just
talked about so concerning that order
will destroy
it will be massive impact on the whole
mesh data structure not happening
what is the order of those polygons
right now
that order looks to be optimized for
the number of points
uh i mean i mean the size
that [ __ ] thing is not going to
affect the order not going to happen
it's ridiculous you just want to
understand what the order is
okay in principle there is there is no
order but when we return them we return
them based on the number of points
right because we stem essentially we
store those those point has packed away
so that's why you see lowered you know
four point five so you're choosing to
sort them here
but your internal data structure does
whatever it does
the internal data structure uses many
optimizations to this
for instance being able to use arrays
and arrays
they need to be of similar size so the
same number of points okay
okay but so fine but but the operation
that one wants to do here
is to say let me extract i mean let's
imagine that what i wanted to do was i
have this voronoi mesh
and now i want to extract the voronoi
cells
that correspond to points one three and
seven how would i do that
how would i do it so we will store the
points for
as annotations on those cells okay but
so how would i actually do the
extraction annotation value
right that's what we agreed on and
now that will tell you that will tell
you for a given cell
what is its what is its related point
i'm asking the question if i want to say
4.7 what is it for and i sell
um introduce i'm sorry turn it out of my
mind we'll introduce that inversion
121 um mesh nearest as such we give you
the closest cell
containing that point oh yeah that's
that works generally
yeah okay it's fine all right
okay onward um
what does that mean what is a conformal
conforming triangulation
okay so actually i realized there's a
piece there that we were still working
on the documentation to
give a better description of so
you can have um constraints basically
when you do triangulations
yeah like how pointy can the triangles
get no
but the constraints can be you want this
line segment to be part of the
triangulation
you want um yeah line segment in the
case of triangulations and
you know triangles and other things in
for for tetrahedralizations
so those those need to be included
there and then so those are those are
conforming if it's constrained
it meant it's not necessarily delawny
if it's conforming it's necessarily
delany
okay okay
so okay do should i look at this page or
not i think it's not there yet we were
working on but i realized that we didn't
have our revisits to to look at it
okay it's not there right charles
um i i think i put it if we have a
latest update i mean just some
okay well then then go and look but i
haven't haven't seen it yet we were
still
still sort of working on that to be able
to explain that in a clean and clear way
sandra is commenting here that he would
expect so let's see we take a bunch of
random points we've all annoyed
those points we
okay let's try it then
okay
so what is this doing mesh primitives
well mesh primitives gets you the prim
the the polygons
but with points substituted in instead
of the indexes
um and
oh this is this question whether it
returns in the right order
right this this doesn't oh it's just the
words
this doesn't work because the order is
not because the order is right follow us
that's not a that's not a contract that
we're going to sign on we've never
signed on we've never signed up to do
not going to happen right but so in in
the new form where there are annotations
instead of saying points here you could
be saying annotation value
of that mesh primitive instead of that
point
yes and then you can get the
the primitive that you can get the
polygon that way
yes i understand okay
let's go back over here
is this some
it's not there okay all right okay well
that's not let's not let's not
handle that right now but we'll need to
come back to this at some point
okay lovely um
okay
positive orientation it's what we seek
in everybody
um
boy this is confusing what's a q
function and what's not
we need to have a further discussion
about this and this is the right group
right but we do need it soon because
this this as i said this
uh schedule an lcc meeting about queue
okay yeah and let's bring up these
examples
right because because what is the issue
with coplanar queue
it's the same thing that it can have
parameters so you get a condition
you get a boolean condition that that
will evaluate to true or false with
concrete values for those things but but
cannot return true or false
as is yeah i understand i understand
that it's an unsignable contract for us
the q contract
right now right but the question is we
change q or do we do something different
with condition
or whatever how does that work exactly
because
i'll i'll push for that meeting fine
and and i also want to understand for
these things specifically i want to
understand their correspondence to
geometric assertion
because all of those issues except
coplana because we don't have 3d
will be things that show up in in
geometric assertion
possibly under different names
make sense charles
and i don't understand what positive
orientation is does that mean
clockwise and counterclockwise yes
yeah okay so let's understand i think
this is a general nd
positive orientation what is the what is
the generalization
of clockwise and then dimensions it's uh
the right hand rule
in 3d okay and in general it's a
determinant with positive sign
or the position compared to the
hyperplane yes
it's another way to get intuition for it
tell me there's a hyperplane defined by
a bunch of points and then there's
another point that's being added
is that what you're saying yes
sorry i don't quite understand the the
um so you've got
what is it is it some kind of wedge
product
that you're doing that generates the
final point so to speak it's the
anti-symmetric
that's what you say determinate you say
you take the coordinates
of the points the whatever they are then
you form
the totally anti-symmetric you form
the open the page it's down there
stephen it's nicely explained i think
p1 p2 p3
okay but p4 i wouldn't call it p4 i
would call that
p star or something because it's not
really a point
in that collection right it's a it's a
manufactured point
or did i misunderstand something
no it's not the manufacturer yes it is
yes it is
positive orientation of p1p2 2p3
is a right hand rule where there's been
a point p4 constructed
from p1 p2 p3 you see that the diffusion
you are looking above there is the 2d
do no no i'm looking at this one here
looking at this case here right you're
saying positive
but it's the same in 2d you take away
i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry yes yes yes yes yes
yes
i'm confused yeah there was that
question that you know
essentially like you point also the q4
the p4 in this case you know kind of an
independent point right if you think
about it because
first in dimension and the end first
point
kind of they find the hyper plane and
then the n plus one point
kind of the last one that's fake
right that is a nice way to think about
it yeah i agree
right what is this just for my education
in terms of totally anti-symmetric
tenses and so on what is this thing
is this the signature if i do this it is
basically a wedge product
um it's the um
it's epsilon ijk whatever it is and then
with all of the points fed into that i
think
it's a determinant as you say of all the
all the
determinant of the list of um of
coordinate values
right yes okay fine
i mean yeah you see the determinant
definition at the last line there
right nice well nice function bad name
we'll fix that okay
um wonderful okay linear gradient
filling okay so this is you really need
to open those
they're very nice so this is graphics
now
yep do we have brett here or is this
is this non a non-brett form of graphics
this is non-breadth this is graphics
brett is visualization
oh roger you always make this
distinction i always get confused by it
so okay so these are various effects for
so this is the analog
so let me just understand so this is
just just instead of naive stuff this is
if i
say graphics of what is it cross
what do we call it cross hatching hatch
filling disk
okay i get that okay
so this is now so if i say
linear gradient filling
is that prototype well
wrong
i don't see the hello you probably use
regular polygon we
you know use up fix that issue today or
yesterday
okay which way round is it
um it's like i don't know what you mean
does it go
is that point last point in the polygon
oh
from left to right
always from left to right no oh no sorry
that point is the
last named point in the polygon right
yeah that's the last point yes
right which is why circle doesn't work
because it has an infinite number of
named of points in it
right yes it's okay it's going to be
you know but do regular polygon 100 and
look at it it looks like a certain disk
yeah but what's it going to do i'm
trying to understand what's it going to
do for a weird shaped object
no i understand that but my question is
this
there's two ways you could do it you
could either sweep left to right
or you can color
based on in other words if i had a
region here
right why isn't it better to sweep
systematically left to right this is
like the numbering of the
points which you just explained was
undoable so for example if i take my
my previous
look if i take this creature here okay
and i say
um graphics
of that right
why do i get that
well because region is not supported as
a graphics primitive
how do i get the graphics of that region
probably just if that's not you should
take the first of that region
that's true oh that's bad this should
work this should work
yeah we've well we
the last time we discussed about it you
you asked for mesh so we made
much work but we didn't make question
work in general okay so we should make
region work
okay but anyway there it is okay so then
here
i take that presumably and i go here
okay now explain this to me because that
thing
so is it a left to right sweep or is
this
easy yes yes look at the illustration in
the in there
okay so even this was left to right i
was just confused about the about the
points here
no i happen to be one point sticking out
there could be a whole edge being the
last
you know if you take something with it
okay all right fine fine fine fine it's
just the the western mode the
easternmost
point is lighter that's fine okay i get
it
yeah yeah it's nothing to do with points
per se yeah okay i guess
i get it i was confused
see
um do you get that radiant filling yeah
i understand the illustration
so if i were to do linear gradient
filling you know
red to blue here
so this is a dynamic this is a version
of blend
that is a spatial version of blend
basically yeah
is that the only way to do it can i can
i not have something which is a smoother
blending you can say where
because you can specify you can see it's
can you see that and yeah i can respect
it i can see that okay
where it's a list of points and a list
of colors basically
can i give can i give a position arrow
color as well i think i should be able
to do that the transpose of this
i don't know charles does that work
i think it should work okay so so here
if i
say if i say in this i say
so position is it a position x y
position or merely an x position
merely an x
i think that the name position is a bit
confusing here because it's
it's just a zero one okay so if i say
point two arrow red
point five arrow yellow
and i'm going to be mean minus point
four
arrow blue and i get an error
um well we don't yet support that form
so if you write
point 2.5
okay so hold on so this is i bet that
surprised you
you were sure to find another bug no
i wasn't sure i just suspected it
to be honest i think charles just
derived that so it has a
basically what it deals with intervals
outside zero one
is is a periodic continuation of zero
one
so whatever you term saying
that's a little weird
well this part when you get out of
mind i mean away from one minus one i
mean the bound zero one
it's it's probably not white so this
needs to be
let's think about this so what you're
doing here is you're making
at this point at the point 0.2 it's pure
red
right yes so i claim there needs to be
an interpolation order here in color
space because i think this looks kind of
stupid to have these
have these actual lines because i can
see i assume you can see it
through through the web conferencing
thing that you can see this really
highlights the the pure red the pure
yellow line
does it for you yes oh that's
interesting
interpolation order yeah
that's what i would suggest and that way
because i think that's good so one of
the things here is that we
one of the languages we've looked at for
this too to be compatible with
is svg um
i don't know if they have interpolation
order but i think that we have now
it's nicely compatible both ways
no most of the 10 people just do it they
line up the blind form
and it's just that those colors are
so non-compatible sandra is asking if
this can have opacity
i would have seen
no opacity point five is not a color but
if you
have a color but this is a color opacity
point five comma yellow is a color
you should make that work that's a
perfectly valid color
what's that oh i mean i
was just not aware of that i think it is
unless i'm crazy and let's
let's i think if i say graphics of this
it is yeah yeah okay
okay fine so okay so there's an
interpolation in the alpha channel as
well as in the color space
right
so right so so it's got to interpolate
independently and
and rgb i don't know whether it's
interpolating i mean
you know clearly the the the
interpolation order in rgb space depends
on whether it's rgb space or xyz space
or whatever else right and then the
interpolation right now
it just does rgb is rgb is
what people expect is the one which is
the most efficient to run
okay fine okay but but anyway so this is
this is just a simple
simple thing here right yes
okay so okay so then
if i go like this yeah i really think
you should try and avoid those
those those bright lines so to speak
we have um so one of the things that
we've done
here which is that we wanted a richer
set of gradients that people can call on
so um and maybe you have an idea
okay but basically what we've done
is is it a data repository item and we
use resource
is the results well right so we
allow for a ton of other strings
hundreds of other strings
just as we allow for hundreds of other
strings in net model
yes good idea okay and so if you go down
and and presumably you're doing that
just like when you have icons plot
markers we allow for many strings right
for plot markers
yeah those are kind of there's not
there's not super many strings there
here we go seriously many
and you can go but we should be able to
do that plot markers
so the way that works for neural nets
right it's its own net model
okay just just to review how that works
you you know how that works or
shall i review how that works yes yes i
know how it works
okay but just to say it i mean you know
every
net model is a resource object of type
net model
but then net model pulls in net model is
specialized just like resource data is
just
calling resource objects which have
names to some
you know where their simple name
disambiguation but it's a
resource object of type uh
you know data or whatever it is that is
then pulled in so what you're suggesting
is
for plot markers we should do this too
is to have a repository
so one question is do we want a combined
repository
of things like plot markers textures i
mean i could imagine a repository of
textures
et cetera et cetera et cetera how do we
want to do this i mean to me
it seems like gradients textures etc
those are the same kind of thing
sort of i mean i don't think we really
quite i mean we are gearing up for doing
more textures in the next release um
okay
um this is the one place where we can do
something
now not block markers and these other
things yeah okay i understand
i understand i understand so what you're
saying is
and i think it should be in the examples
if nothing oh god
remember documentation is not
documentation if it's only in examples
where can i see it charles is it an
application sir
remember charles charles you understand
that principle it's not documented if
it's only in the examples
yeah we haven't documented it yet
because
it's not just in the resource the part
of call out data is actually documented
so okay so hold on where should i be
looking here
um basic i think gradient color the
second
application section
wait a minute this is a color data
so wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute okay so let's just
just hold on a second let me try to
understand this okay so first point is
even color data should really be a
resource system play
right yeah
kind of yes it should be it should be
that's the right way to do it
so okay so let's understand that so so
that's the thing that
that probably you guys should talk to
the resource system
team about so color data becomes
a resource object of type color whatever
it is
um
then it's not a small change there's a
ton of things that you know it's not a
small change
really it doesn't just as far as your
system is concerned doesn't it just call
color data and get a color back
yes right so the question of where
the color data doesn't no longer work no
no color data would work fine no
what i'm suggesting roger is that color
data is backed by the resource system
okay which gives us a documentation
channel for color data
do you see what i'm saying oh
i see right and sandra is commenting
that color data
hasn't been updated for a decade which
he's complaining about rightly so
so what i'm suggesting it's not quite
sandor we've added
lots of things but the the overall
structure is the same
right so what i'm suggesting is that
color data
instead of it's just being sort of this
mysterious thing that has
you know that goes through this
that that effectively becomes
that you know that there's a resource
system
thing like the neural net repository
which is the color color data repository
so to speak
that has each one of these things has a
documentation page
blah blah blah see what i'm saying so
then we can add whatever you want to
that
people can can contribute yeah i mean
this is exactly where we
where i was we were getting to here but
we cannot we could not
that that's fine okay it's fine not for
this version but i mean
but what i'm suggesting is that the only
thing color data the only thing the
resource system is doing for you there
is providing a documentation and you
know
extension track basically
yeah so if you look here the next one
there's several hundred ui gradients
that people have developed
okay so this is 400
300 yeah but a little bit less okay fine
so you want to put these in in a a
color gradients i mean you know
the natural thing to do would be okay
either they're just available in this
function
or you could have a color gradients data
which pulls them in either way
but i don't know whatever but go ahead
yeah i said the plan was then to
actually have a color gradient you know
resource to actually pull it out that's
fine
that sounds like a good idea and that
should be extremely straightforward to
implement
i mean like trivial right the only thing
that will be non-trivial
is the structure of the documentation
pages
in the color gradient yeah i don't think
every gradient needs a
page you know but roger that's just the
way this works
just give it a freaking page it's okay
and and we also now have guide pages for
repositories okay but
let me just just uh ask what you or do
you think we should have a new
repository or a data
a new repository i would have a new
repository because i think
it's a question of how you're going to
use these things if these things have
look the neural net repository could be
the data repository
but you know frankly the documentation
of these will be kind of stupid
in a data repository form right
these want different documentation i
would recommend having its own
repository
or i was teetering because it didn't
feel like it felt like it's an
interesting use case but it's not big
enough
and well okay so i've got two
suggestions two possible suggestions and
they may or may not make sense
okay we've got a number of other things
like icon data
which could be its own repository right
or
i mean look repositories were intended
to be somewhat lightweight
they've been used in a fairly
heavyweight fashion i mean i fully
expect it will have 50 kinds of
repositories
like axiomatic theory is about to get
its own repository
okay and you know
right now we've got only 20 or 30
axiomatic theories but we're going to
have a bunch more
and each one needs a documentation page
so why not
basically use the repository system to
do that
but so i mean what we've got for for you
know we've got icon data we've got plot
marker data
we've got color data we've got your
gradient data
the question that i have is do all of
those things
should they all be one kind of
repository in one repository
right that they're something like um you
know
graphic objects repository yeah i don't
know
i think it's going to take some working
through here okay so here's what
because we have plot themes there's
another one that that seems obvious
um yeah i i think they should be
separate repositories
i think it's okay you know plot theme
repository you understand what it is
it's okay it's a plot theme repository
it's got a top-level page it's
it's all you know it's got a big guide
page about plot themes
and that guide page will be different
from the guide page
about gradients because the plot themes
guide page will show
samples of plots the gradients thing
will just show the gradient
etc as i say i think i think
the only non-trivial thing about a
separate repository is
is the pattern for its documentation
pages
that make sense yeah
so that that you have to define
um it's a question for okay sandra is
asking is it blended in rgb space or lab
space
it's blended in rgb space and so i know
sander
if you if you if you give a non-linear
space
like hsv or or um
you know lab or something that's not
that's not really the correct thing to
do
right if you if your colors are in those
other spaces but
but as bob is pointing out thinks that
better algorithms do color blending than
taking the average rgb values
yes and i'm sure blend uses better
algorithms
right but we're not using blend here are
we or are we
because we're not in a position to use
blend because that's not are these
things running in gpus
is this is yes it's running in gpus
okay so i mean in the future we might
choose
you know we might be able to change the
default algorithm to use something
fancier
um yes i mean for rgb blending in rgb
is optimal and for the linearly related
spaces like xyz
cmy it doesn't matter it's gonna give it
it's commutative it's the same thing
so if you use a non-linear sorry
you know anyway i mean at the end right
we
we we can do we can do all that we can
do the operation in
in each space but we just need to do the
conversion and the mapping
right and if there is a wide demand down
the knee then we can do it but it's
it's
push is asking how is this represented
internally and i don't know the answer i
mean this is just
some function that i don't know what
this is
holiday now it's effectively using
wrappers around an interpolating
function
okay okay but look and
and sandra is commenting that balanced
hue is not documented which i don't know
what that
i mean look basic bottom line is we need
a color data repository
okay and i suggest you guys get with
um brad and so on to define how that
works
and i'm happy to be part of that but the
test roger
what i think you need to do is just make
up what would you like to see on a
documentation page for one of these
things
and to be honest with a colored data
documentation page really it's just a
freaking picture of the color
you know it's just a big version of that
picture that's all you really need to
see
that and you need to see see also to
other related
you know you might want to see for
example a custom version of c also
in which you see the actual color
gradients in the sea also if you see
what i mean
does that make sense yeah i mean there's
actual design
i mean some of them sure sure i got that
but
we have designed a bunch of of of new
color data
um color lists for instance for charting
which we're you know the original ones
were tended to be smooth
but smooth colors next to each other
yeah don't it's really bad in a pie
you can't tell them apart right so i've
got a couple of comments here so in the
color data
repository one of the other nice things
is that you can have examples
for a given you know have two things you
have examples like using it in geo
region value plot or something
you can have see also with with actual
color things
so you know i think it's really a useful
thing and
why don't yeah okay so let's go back to
this so i understand this should use the
repository and you could do that right
now
you can just create the resource objects
you don't necessarily have to have
we did we did that's what was already
done
okay um
the uh okay great um
okay so that's so that's what you're
doing for linear
linear gradient so linear gradient
is basically an orientation
what happens to a linear gradient on a
three-dimensional object
the filling only works in 2d 3d okay so
it's hatching
what is it called in 3d shading
yeah the things that operate on surfaces
are different and we don't have anything
like this
right and we also don't need i mean
since we live in
in roughly at least three-dimensional
space
we have a limited number of cases we
have to deal with
for now yeah
um okay
uh let's look at this so so grady radial
has what parameters it presumably has to
know
i mean what happens if that's not a
circle
so radial is with respect to its center
point
and you support the you know radii for
the ellipse
cases yeah but where's the center of
each ellipse
oh there is just one center so the
concentric circle
but where's the center is it the is it
the center
speaking scale 0.5 0.5
meter of the bonding box
is that the right country what shouldn't
you be able to parameterize the center
i mean do you ca it doesn't matter it is
it is parameterized the last case
oh okay so the x y okay is it always
along the coordinate directions
and what happens okay i've got a couple
of questions here if i
change the um let me look at something
here
um so if i say linear instead of saying
this i say
radial gradient filling
okay a little bit weird i mean that that
you know the or
that that circle is a little bit okay so
now my big question is
if i change the aspect ratio of this
picture what is going to happen
okay i guess that makes sense
so in other words whatever you set
as the ellipsoidal semi major and seven
minor axes
they will be scaled by the aspect ratio
correct
yes and now if i were to make this
how do i do that polygon at a certain
angle i can say an r and a theta here so
i can say
uh 1
30 degrees
why didn't that do anything am i
confused
i mean a disc will pretty much look like
a disc no no no i i moved
no why didn't that change the axis
oh i mean if you do no no no no no
the starting of the rotation yeah so if
you do seven points you can kind of
probably or
five or something yeah i might do four
okay there we go
okay so this is so if i had aspect ratio
one then that would look like a square
with a
with that circularly in it okay
so what happens if i want to change the
orientation
of the semi-major axis here yeah we
don't support that
i mean most of the people um
yes if we add this specification but
i i don't know whether we can
particularly but i mean it seems like a
but this radial thing what is it
typically used for
what do you mean for graphic effects you
know
i mean so this is used this is partly in
sort of in graphics design right so you
might have
um um
this these are used for ui elements
these are used for
anything illustration anything for
graphics designer
what does tim want to use this for
i mean usually like most of the web page
or most like
you know we just say graphic design and
if you look even the basic example that
you show even some basic visualization
where it's
actually nice to have a gradient has a
background
okay to you know convey more additional
information and such
i mean all of our charting would
obviously use this
um because we we sort of faked it when
we did charting since we didn't have
this
okay so sandra is commenting that aspect
ratio
is this inconsistent aspect ratio
between hatch filling
and that's keeping the same angle here
am i confused what's going on here no
but this angle this never has an angle
right
this is always on the on the coordinate
axis so it doesn't have the system
okay okay where's the basic examples for
radial
you can sort of think of it as a stencil
you know your primitive is a stencil
yeah i understand so this is kind of
giving us
i mean just yesterday somebody was
suggesting glowing
for some what was that for that was a
glow oh gosh what were you looking at
yesterday
um radial axis plot
yes
oh hypno glow right that was what uh
what we were looking at yesterday
that was some style called right but and
so that is that achievable with radial
gradient filling
i don't know maybe
yes if you have a sequence of polygons
you can pretty much emulate it
okay well this looks nice i mean i'm not
completely sure
i see radial gradient filling open close
black in the middle makes sense
makes good sense makes sense i can see
why this will be relevant for ui
elements
have we shown this to jeremy and and and
and so on
no can we do that could we do that
um just just to see if there's any
further comments
it looks nice um
okay all right let's look at okay so the
conic
case is what is that that will have
parameters associated with its
with how the cone
um
i see so that's around a circle
but i can't combine these right i can't
have something that varies
um
yeah bob is saying does this mean we can
now import other svg graphics but then
saying not the people use svg much
don't they what do they use i thought
people were using svg
yeah svg is a common
uh if you want the vector format what
else you gonna use all right
okay so this means the red
what angles are these things at
if i've got two things so conic is
equivalent to linear
if i'm am i right you can see the
coordinates there on that second
illustration
probably should have been on the first
one too in the in the guide and a
reference page
see so the first
element goes what is happening here why
is this
so we go with so we uniformly split in
this case the
the cycle between zero and two pi okay
so with the positive x-axis being the
zero
and you know we don't like no we
we go counterclockwise
and we are not starting percent 0
because the red will be
maybe in this case a power of 6 or so
so we kind of uniformly split the space
to position them and then so essentially
at the beginning there is roughly
a range of you know
from zero to one and the
step of one over
you've completely lost me too i'm i'm
breaking this
this radial i mean this angular
region into i start at zero
in in standard theta r theta coordinates
right zero
is the positive x axis and my
other choice so if i were to go red to
red
right i would just be uniform red right
if i'm not mistaken am i confused here
that's a bug yes bug
i am so proud of myself with the number
of bugs i'm managing to find
no that one i kind of made the decision
that the one argument
i think you just bought one argument why
not it just does means uniform
okay we can just evaluate that okay yeah
um okay but so once we have two here
that says positive x-axis is red
negative x-axis is yellow
right why am i confused here and if i
were to go
red yellow blue i would get that
yellow would be um at um
pi two pi over three blue will be there
okay that's what i expect right
okay so so far so good so now is there
any issue is there any further issue
here that looks like it's the story
and then if you want i see that you've
got the theta values and radians here if
you want to give them
um
okay okay
so
um right okay i mean that seems
uncontroversial to me
this thing here and
and and this says the center of the cone
in this case i can say the center
is 0.5 let's say 1
0.
let's move it in a bit
say 0.50
that confuses me why is the center of
that code not
o with respect to the bounding box
it's not with respect to user
coordinates
i don't think that's right i think you
should say scale if you want it relative
to the bounding box
yeah so i oh okay sorry in this case we
forgot to put scale angle
i mean we didn't put that there it
should be scaled yes
no i'm saying this here should be in
user coordinates why isn't that in user
coordinates
i don't want that in scaled coordinates
so i wanted in scale coordinates i would
have said scaled otherwise
if i want conic gradient filling on
seven different pic you know
dancing elephants in my picture right
i want to know coordinates of the
dancing elephants and i want to put the
conic gradient filling
centered on the the head of the dancing
elephant
not in some weird scaled coordinates
you see what i'm saying i claim that
centering should be in user coordinates
do you disagree
i yes because we went down that part
um so i'm just trying to have my mind
back
on that so the point is that when you
say using a coordinate
right it's referred to the actual object
we draw
right like in this case you have a
regular polygon
right so essentially so you mean we need
to compute the plot range
locate the user coordinates in that
blood pressure and do that and i think
that was not possible
okay well then what i would recommend we
do is to say that we used to document it
as using scaled
yes and maybe one day we'll be able to
do user coordinates there
right as in documented by saying the
thing we support is scaled at 0.50
well it's not they say really scale
because scale is with respect to the
plot range
so what is it with respect to it's
respect to the bounding box
of the actual object
oh wow
this concerns me a bit
i don't think that's quite right i
understand what you're doing but nothing
else works that way does it
okay we have some questions and comments
on livestream here let me just go
through this a bit
um
[Music]
um okay so push is saying the case of
texture lookup one could use color
gradient for height maps
as well as bump mapping yes but we we
don't have the texture repository yet
um
okay there's a question about pdf export
are we having to rasterize these
pdf export
this has not yet sort of made it there
but i think initially it will be
rasterized
whether that sort of an updated pdf
export can export it directly i hope so
right okay they're they're they're
what the people say that work on that
they will say there are too many other
elements that cannot be
uh you know mapped into pdf so we might
as well bitmap it all
yeah but well it's worth exploring
because i know that this is a sore point
at least for the first version it's kind
of what we are likely on
what was wrong with this why isn't that
oh
oh no i know i'm giving the coordinate
in the wrong place
why is oh yes i do want the graphics of
it
am i giving the coordinates in the right
place
lovely magnificent
that's quite magnificent what's up the
number
that was quite fast quite zippy
why is there so much greenery there
that's very nice
what's up the number
what's that okay no no this is very
respectable
3 000 it's very respectable
yeah that's really good
actually i haven't seen that before
how could i not have a graphics section
here
um okay well good all right so so
one flag there for the for this question
about what the xy means i'm a little
concerned about that
but otherwise this seems reasonable and
it seems like the
the padding
what is this
why do you have to do that what is this
padding thing
so um i mean the best is to start with
the case of the linear
uh criterion filling so if you specify
the value between
you know zero and one so
the range and you know instead of
starting at zero you start for example
at point
two to point eight right
five here on the left and right i see
okay fine
yep um
okay is tech exports supported i assume
these pictures can be exported as tech
although they have the same
rasterization behavior as for pdf
yeah um okay this is really nice
i'm getting really hungry though and i'm
gonna run i'm super late
okay all right so let we'll continue
this we'll have to pull
in another um the uh
um we'll have to do one more iteration
of this
sure um
but these are mostly these are 3d
graphics formats
and is this allowing us to get closer to
importing generic cad files and things
not these ones um
but is this for export that we can do
boundary mesh region and so on is this
for import here
import i didn't know byu supported
mesh complicated meshes
i thought it was a very simple format no
okay well that's good can we do this for
export as well
that we can take boundary mesh or we've
already been able to yes
yes yeah you could do that
but they are fundamentally graphics you
know they're dcc formats digital content
creation formats
so their emphasis and correctness in
geometry is sort of
often questionable and they're often
produced by some
graphics program that makes it look good
but be geometrically incorrect
yes i understand all right
sounds great all right good stuff i was
i'm pleased to see these fillings i had
not really
i mean i hadn't i known these were
coming they're nice
is that a fairly complete set or are
there like a whole zoo of other ones
that we
still have to think about of fillings
yeah we have nothing more planned for
filling right now i think but
okay there's shading fillings there's a
lot of shading's coming
okay spellings are full but we've got
more to do in other things
yes um all right great stuff
good work all right thanks and thanks to
folks on the live stream
and we'll see you another